et l'on reparle de la grippe aviaire ce
virus qui touche les volailles ne se
limite plus seulement à l'asie du sud
est et à la chine depuis quinze jours
déjà les élevages de russie sont
également touchés par l'épidémie ce
virus peut se transmettre à l'homme et
les contaminations entre humains sont
rares pour l'instant reste que les
scientifiques se prépare à tous les
scénarii et jean daniel flaysakier
jacques gérard à bord de ce vol de
migrateurs qui se pose près de
novossibirsk en sibérie
il ya un passager bien indésirables le
virus h5n1 le virus de la grippe aviaire
ce germe tant redouté a donc quitté
l'asie du sud-est pour s'inviter en
russie les autorités ont déjà dû
sacrifier 65 mille volailles pour
juguler l'infection mais tous les
observateurs ont le regard fixé sur la
chine le vietnam et guettent avec
angoisse l'arrivée de l'automne cette
région du monde est une gigantesque
ferme à ciel ouvert où les paysans
cohabitent dans une incroyable
promiscuité avec les canards les
volailles les cochons
le danger c'est que le virus h5n1 et le
virus humain se rencontrent à un moment
ou un autre chez le porc par échange de
matériel génétique le virus aviaire
pourrait alors s'humaniser être capable
d'infecter des millions de personnes
face au spectre des pandémies comme
celle de 1918 la fameuse grippe
espagnole ou bien encore celle de 1957
les chercheurs réfléchissent à des
modèles de prévention l'oise deux études
publiées hier montrent que le pire est
évitable à certaines conditions
si nous détectons les tout premiers cas
humains si nous leur donnons des
médicaments antiviraux ainsi que leur
entourage
ici on ferme les écoles et les usines on
peut imaginer stopper la propagation de
l'épidémie
il faudra être sûr de disposer d'une
quantité suffisante du seul médicament
efficace il faudra aussi que les pays
concernés signal très vite les premiers
cas suspects or par le passé la chine
n'a pas toujours joué le jeu c'est
pourtant à ce prix qu'on pourrait éviter
un drame sanitaire planétaire de plus
d'autant qu'aucun vaccin n'est
actuellement disponible